y'all gotta hear this every day whose
idea was this
oh it's a pop
I'm just not you know I'm gonna do this
really light because we don't want to
hear this loud
most outlandish online rumor about you
uh that I was pregnant in the middle of
my grief that was rude oh excuse me can
I curse that was whack I think that's a
fair one to curse at yeah we can bleep
I'm gonna bleep that this is a cute one
it's clear it's matching my outfit
um
biggest difference between you versus
your you people character I've never
dated a White Guy and um I have children
and I'm not a costume designer
I mean this is about to be so loud God
bless you guys oh no have you ever gone
skinny diving
um
I haven't I don't need everybody seen
everything